[Music]
my name is nicko Shire I'm a partner
manager in the play eft partnerships
team in berlin germany and it's my
absolute pleasure to be here with all of
you today did you guys have fun at the
concert last night
me too and I have a sore throat to prove
it
hello everybody my name is Gina I'm on
the Play apps partnerships team here in
Mountain View like me go I'm super
excited to welcome you here to our
sessions tools and tips to boost user
engagement and retention IO 2017 has
been incredibly exciting with a lot of
great announcements we heard that the
Android ecosystem has grown tremendously
with the number of developers that have
over a million monthly installs that
have grown 35 percent in the last year
there are 2 billion monthly active
Android devices today and people have
downloaded 82 billion apps from the Play
Store that's amazing and it's all the
hard work that you have put in so give
you around selves a round of applause in
the last three days we have had so many
really inspiring conversations with
developers such as yourself here at i/o
and they have come and told us how
they're excited for this session because
boosting engagement within their apps is
one of the most important topics for
them and we find it exciting indeed we
of course completely agree that boosting
user engagement is a key topic if you
quickly overall quicker recalls sunders
keynote on Wednesday actually he talked
about the reach and also the engagement
that our own products are seeing within
the first probably three minutes of the
keynote but then talking about user
engagement today it's also very humbling
because optimizing for user engagement
is a constant challenge for
developers we totally understand that
and I think we can all agree that losing
user in boosting user engagement is not
a tool it's not a single tip it's not
even a single best practice it's the
combination of a lot of things that have
to be done right and it has to be
constantly optimized in order for it to
work so from our daily work with
developers in different regions and with
different backgrounds we know that even
for the smartest developers staying on
top of all of these details all the time
can be very hard so that is why in
today's session we want to do the
following we're going to give you a
holistic overview of proven best
practices on how to boost user
engagement in apps and to underline that
we are not making this up we actually
have examples from some of the leading
developers around the world to share
with you and to show you that it
actually works so Gina
shall we take a look at what we're going
to cover today absolutely so it starts
with defining your objective for
engagement now if you do not know what
exactly you want your users to engage
you would not know what you want to
boost with a clear objective in mind for
improving engagement then it's all about
testing which optimization can increase
engagement for you yeah and once you
define the once you define the
optimization and get the engagement
objective and you found that feature
that performs best you also want to
release it smartly it's very important
to land it with your users topic number
four we're going to look in today is
great onboarding it's a topic that's
really really close to my heart when it
comes to user engagement it's just such
a crucial step in the users journey also
crucial are smart and successful content
launches to give your users exactly what
they're looking for as well as stimulate
greater and long-term engagement
and finally building an effective
communication strategy specifically
around notifications and that can help
drive for the user awareness wow that's
a lot of things that we're going to be
covering today yep
so Nico do you want to kick it off with
the first one sure let's go right let's
unpack this so defining your engaging
objective really starts with one
something that sounds very simple but
yet can be very tricky to actually get
to you have to have a clear idea of what
your proposition to users what is it
that makes your business stand out what
makes you app on the service you offer
special based on that how is it that you
actually want to use it to engage with
your app let's look at some examples
everybody here knows Airbnb I guess
their value proposition is to let
customers their customers experience
foreign places in a unique way by
staying with locals accordingly for
Airbnb engagement is measured a night
booked and that is what they optimize
for I am is a community by photographers
for photographers their engagement
objective is to get users to upload
photos I am found that users uploading
one photo on day zero increases day 7
retention by 2.5 X even further users
uploading 8 photos over the first 7 days
can be retained over a much longer
period of time very clear objectives
that they can optimize against and that
works at YouTube it's all about watch
hours and so are the optimizations of
the user experience
and lastly 1 football an app that
provides football fans around the world
with live scores and curated football
news they look at different engagement
drivers
with the key one being articles read per
user so as you can see from these
different examples the definition of how
to drive user engagement of what user
engagement means can be quite different
but what all of these examples of these
developers have in common that they
individually have a very clear idea of
their engagement objective and thus how
to drive engagement with their users so
laying out a clear engagement objective
is the basis on which you can optimize
the app experience you can have plenty
of ideas larger smaller features that
you are trying to improve but how are
you going to identify which one actually
drives user engagement you have to do
multiple experiments and run a lot of
tests now start with the hypotheses
develop two or more variants and set up
a test to run about a minimum period of
time so that you can get a statistically
significant result
now individual factors may vary because
of the use cases so let's take a look at
it with an example one football a
popular football app constantly working
towards driving their engagement goals
as Nikko mentioned users reading more
articles with several feature options in
mind they use highways remote config and
that lets them change app components on
the server side and they are not making
any updates to the app itself they're
able to test different variations before
they release the best performing options
to all their users now in this
particular experiment they had three
variations the winning variations saw an
increase of 5% in sessions per user and
also saw an increase of 6% in articles
that users were reading per user as a
result that variation was rolled out to
all the users now this is a great
example of someone who did that with a
combination of three things the
engagement objective that was really
clear those ideas that they have for
optimization
and a tool like firebase remote config
to make it all happen
by the way the one football team is in
the audience quick round of applause
there they are
[Applause]
great job guys so having defined the
objective and run a test with a
successful result is great now you
really want to make sure not to mess it
up when releasing the feature to a large
set of users what do I mean by that that
you want to make sure that the roller is
actually technically stable and the
users actually notice what has changed
to make sure that you land the future
release just follow a very simple
process first ensure that the new build
is technically stable that is just very
important it was mentioned in other
talks before but we see that 50% of
one-star reviews of on Google Play
mentioned topics complaining about AB
stability in box so with that take as a
proxy for happy or unhappy users and
then those users are pretty unhappy and
it's quite simple unhappy users are much
harder to engage and retain right
secondly leverage the features you have
on the Play console such as alpha and
beta groups go to soft launch and then
gradually for a go to full rollout and
then for the user make sure that you
actually visually guide them to what
what's new in the app as you can see
from the material design example on the
slides to support you in this process we
launched a couple of new reports and a
play concert which we strongly recommend
you to use they were discussed in depth
in several other talks which I recommend
you to check out but just very quickly
quickly the pre-launch report and now
provides developers would need more test
coverage and understanding of your app
for example you get a great overview of
key screens across devices secondly the
release dashboard gives you updates on
the release as it happens with hourly
data using both of these reports is the
best practice to release stable updates
and keeping users
tn engaged if we take place or reviews
the proxy another time we see that 60%
of users rating apps with 5 stars
actually praise speeds design and
usability as simple as that
ok on to number 4 my favorite topic user
onboarding user onboarding is a unique
opportunity to learn about user
preferences and show them what is great
about your app a great example of oh
sorry huh so we're optimizing for that
keep a couple of things in mind the
onboarding should be fast seamless and
immersive ideally the onboarding doesn't
see like onboarding ideally it feels
like it's a contextual core part of the
user experience a good example and you
see I got really excited about that
already its health and fitness developer
freeletics so freeletics gets users
really fit through individualized
workout plans about onboarding the guys
from freeletics actually say they don't
onboard users they directly and
progressively emerge them with the
experience so for new users the
immersive product experience really
starts with the onboarding flow where
it's all about the results that they
want to achieve using freeletics based
on the onboarding users get a customized
training plan which engages them as free
athletes to use the app several times a
week to train and become fitter and
healthier another really cool example is
one football once proposed onboarding
process process is designed to drive
engagement through personalization any
football fans in the audience quick show
of hands soccer I'm sorry soccer fans
there we go
so all of you will know what one
footballs research confirms real
football fans mostly care about their
one team so the onboarding experience of
one footballs app is really optimized
for that so after downloading the app
you select which one is your favorite
team I really like our salon then so I
selected them on the second screen
already it's Arsenal themed as you can
see by the red color as a user I can now
pick which of Arsenal's competition I
want to follow once I have done that in
my case I've probably selected all of
them once I've done that I'm done now my
home screen which is what you see now
really sent us about what's most
important to me it's the latest results
of Arsenal in this case that we're going
to play Manchester United a couple of
weeks back further my new stream now
really centers around Arsenal specific
news and actually so do the push
notifications so thanks to a fast very
simple and immersive onboarding
experience the one football experience
is much more personalised relevant and
engaging to the users and while it's not
a must a lot of the advantages of great
onboarding actually come with offering
users login functionality for example if
you really work cross screen you want to
save users preferences login is a super
useful thing to have for your users but
we know that building a account
infrastructure can be complex and
challenging so luckily Google has two
really great solutions for that let's
look at number one Google sign-in lets
users access your app with their Google
login in this example I want to show you
mobile apps it's a budget planning app
from bazzill offers a super quick and
fast login process using Google sign-in
mortgage left are you guys here I know
they were supposed to there we go okay
quick round of applause quick shout out
and so after downloading mobile the user
taps to sign-in with Google they tap to
confirm which account they want to use
from the Google Account selector and
they're in as simple as that super quick
super fast according to the mobile CEO
Carlos Tesoro
logins increased by 300% after
implementing Google sign-in and is now
the most popular choice for logging in
the second solution Google Offers for
developers to make this very easy as
smart lock for passwords with smart lock
for passwords users can log in log into
apps using the credentials they have
saved which the developers you can
retrieve with a specific API so the
example here or there as well shows JA
Co jazz is a calorie counting app that
helps users develop a healthier
lifestyle so after my week here I ate
lots of burgers and I want to go back
and live a healthier lifestyle
so download jazzy oh and from here the
flow is super simple I select my goal
which is stay healthy and and after that
jar lets me create an account it's very
straightforward to eat the smart log
email picker lets me pick which email I
want to use for my account
the details are prefilled and I only
have to add the password and I'm done
I'm in and I can start using the app
implementing smart lock significantly
improved the signing experience for
Jazzy users and saw some great results
actually sign up conversions increased
by 14% and over 70% of those users used
an email address that was suggested I
mean why wouldn't you I hate typing in
my email address myself
so for personalized app like Jojo that
really depends on having my user
preferences saved this is really crucial
to engage users and a great example on
how to use smart lock for that thank you
so the insights that you learn from your
users preference during onboarding that
can be leveraged as you think about
boosting engagement with successful
content launches now what do I mean by
that game developers have successfully
done this in the form of live ops have
you heard of live ops before okay let me
tell you they are a key focus for game
developers at the moment and there are
interesting insights for app developers
would simply live ops is running games
as a service think of it as the game
becoming a dynamic product that is
constantly changing giving players new
experiences every day the goal of live
ops is to augment engagement stimulate
monetization and reduce player churn we
see three components - lie box we see
content we see sales and events and this
combination has proved very successful
for game developers now in the context
of apps let me show that with an example
memorize their an innovative language
learning app are you guys in the
audience okay so an innovative language
learning app run it back to school offer
in September last year to motivate users
to start early when the school year
starts they release beginner and
advanced versions of new language
combinations and ran a global campaign
that also offered discount for their
annual subscription program this was a
great success for them and it actually
boosted additional engagement from this
particular campaign and resulted in over
percent increase in revenue lastly and
probably more importantly an effective
communication strategy that can be a
great way to make users aware of all the
features that can drive engagement app
push notifications are not new to anyone
they're not new to us they're not new to
us as a developer or as a user and
there's so much innovation happening
happening there now and it's a good time
to revisit your strategy around push
notifications so let's go through some
of the main characteristics of good
notifications I say notification but
these are also applicable to other
channels of communication like in-app
messaging emails relevance sounds simple
you want to send messages that are
relevant to the user right but it can be
really hard to find out what is relevant
so think about sending messages that
matter to the user in the context that
they're in be mindful of the tone you
use be mindful of the language that you
select also be creative and true to your
brand one way of ensuring that is to
actually give them the option to let
them select various alternatives
during the onboarding flow actionable
notifications can sometimes be used to
inform and sometimes update content as
well as allow users to take specific
actions whatever action or info that you
want to show in your notification you
want to make sure that that is also
accounted for in the engagement metrics
personalized were not equal so are your
users they're not created equal
for effective communication segment your
user base create cohorts and find
customized ways to tailor your messaging
to them also give them options to opt-in
and opt-out or filter proactively
timeliness raise your hands if you have
ever received not important messages or
notifications just when you
to bed hey so right message at the right
time and at the right frequency can
drive user engagement consider the day
of the week consider the time zone that
they're in and sometimes you can also
give them one-click alternatives like
read later on Android rich notifications
are incredibly valuable and it's a
valuable surface that drives meaningful
engagement and with every release we are
enhancing the feature set take a look at
what we are launching with Android Oh in
the preview and there are many features
on our notifications that are coming as
part of Android Oh so let's take a look
at some examples
The Guardian do not judge me of the
example with whatever the political
inclinations that we have but let's take
the look at this example which is a
great example of how they drove user
engagement with their mobile app during
the recent u.s. election by using new
notifications functionality in Android n
they used innovative techniques to give
their users a rich real-time update on
the election results as they happened as
you can see the notifications are super
creative they use avatars they had a
real time a progress bar to give you
real-time updates in a creative manner
and lots of up-to-date results The
Guardian saw an impressive engagement of
about 170,000 users who signed up to see
the alert with an average of 5
interactions per user another important
characteristic as I mentioned before is
when notifications are actionable
whenever possible citymapper is an app
that gives users smart commute
notifications and it uses an FYI for
your information type of notifications
at the relevant times of the user
according to Gilbert rhythm
the head of Design at citymapper
notifications on Android and therefore
delivering notification and information
right to the users lock screen is such a
powerful feature for them then
notification for daily commute updates
with real-time information it's really
useful for all their users who are
commuting and using that information
during the commute and it's a great way
to update their users on any changes
that take place and drive daily
reengagement to the app I want to share
another example of creating relevance by
combining innovative technologies and
I'm going to highlight store card who
enables you to manage loyalty cards on
your phone then use the awareness API to
notify you when you're near a chain
store with loyalty points that you are
tracking now what is awareness API the
awareness API unifies seven locations
and contextual signals into a single API
enabling you to create powerful context
based experiences for your user with
minimal impact on system resources so
now you can combine potentially
processed context signals in new ways
that were not previously available to
you while letting the API manage system
resources so that your app doesn't have
to finally in terms of tools that you
can use to drive effective notifications
I want to highlight firebase
notifications this is a free service
that enables targeted user notification
for mobile app developers it is based on
firebase cloud messaging and provides an
option if you need a flexible
notification system that requires little
in effort to get started they integrate
very closely with firebase analytics so
now you can target notifications by
customizing audiences now with
notifications targeted to user segments
you can contact exactly the right user
at the right time with updates on
available upgrades features that you're
launching on any other news that you
want them to know and this works across
Android iOS and web great so here we go
six key area areas for you to optimize
your app in to boost user engagement
start with clearly defining your
objectives test your features and then
if you have a winner
release it smartly leverage the
opportunity that onboarding provides
it's really a key moment in the user
journey work and you can learn about
users preferences and then strategically
Lounge contents and most importantly
follow all of the superb tips about
effective notifications Gena just
provided so that is a good list of
things to get right and constantly
improve yet we want to recommend you
another area to optimize engagement in
your abs behavioral insights it is a
super hot topic like super hot our
expert Jenny Fisher put over one year of
research into it and cover this in a
dedicated talk early this morning so if
you didn't get the chance to check it
out yet
we recommend you to follow the link on
the slide and then we're probably going
to put it in the video description as
well to learn all about how to leverage
behavioural insights to boost user
engagement and retention
so we covered a lot of ground with you
today and really hope it resonated with
you what do you think yeah cool thanks
and we do fully appreciate that it's a
lot of information this is day three
you've had heard a lot of great sessions
you have watched a lot of great sessions
on live streams I hope but it was every
session the most important thing remains
what are you going to do differently
after this talk what's next well for
today you want to make it very easy for
you we appreciate that it's warm you
hear you want to go out and enjoy the
Sun enjoy the rest of the talks and then
probably have a cool drink so for now
all we want you to do is note down this
link nothing more write it down or type
it in your phone or take a picture I
will give you a moment to actually do
that
cool
then you can go and enjoy the rest of Io
but on Monday or even if you even if
it's Sunday when you go back to work go
to the link what you will find is our
app and get app engagement checklist to
download it helps you it reminds you of
all the areas you can optimize to boost
user engagement and actually provides a
set of questions you can use you can ask
yourself or you can ask your team to
identify the area and where your app
engagement has to have more room for
improvement so download this and use it
go through the questions and then start
optimizing with the tips you learn today
and of course everything you learned
across the last couple of days and
capture the full opportunity Google Play
offers to you as a developer and with
that thank you thank you very much
[Music]